so how can we ensure accountability for
how american taxpayer funds and weapons
are used congressman greg stooby sits on
the house foreign affairs committee and
he joins us now congressman so great to
have you here this morning um so you
actually supported the war um in ukraine
you voted for funding uh for for ukraine
for hundreds of millions of dollars now
this amount says 10 point
whatever billion dollars you say you
haven't received even one report of
accountability
i voted for the first tranche which was
that 10.2 billion dollars the second
tranche was 40 billion dollars we spent
a total of 54 billion dollars in ukraine
i voted against that last funding amount
because there was no guard rails as to
how that money was going to be spent
congress still hadn't gotten any
information and i said on the foreign
affairs committee foreign affairs
members haven't been given information
on did the weapons that we transferred
actually get into the ukrainians hands
have they been utilized have they been
spent do they need more what is the
status of all of this have the money
gone to oligarchs in ukraine we don't
know the the administration isn't
answering any of our questions and there
was no guard rails in that last funding
toronto 40 billion dollars which oh by
the way is more than uh customs border
patrol border protection coast guard
combined uh we need to be focused on
america first and not all of these other
issues throughout the world is this the
pentagon who's responsible for giving
you this report
it's the state department and the
pentagon they kind of go back and forth
the way the biden administration has
done it like the afghanistan bots
withdrawal the state department was
actually in charge of that uh that
process so the state department is in
charge of most of the funding in ukraine
but some of it is military defense
transfers so it's partly department of
defense partly department of state
so if the republicans take control of
congress can you use the power of the
purse to say we're going to withhold
funding from you know
certain programs in the state department
or the pentagon if you don't give us
this report is that one way you can deal
with it how do you get the pentagon and
the state department to do their job
well not only is it the power the purse
that we'll have when we take the
majority back it's the power of
oversight democrats in congress aren't
going to oversee joe biden's horrible
administration we will finally be a
check and balance to the decisions that
his administration is making bringing in
their officials deposing them having
subpoena authority that's where the real
power is going to come when we take the
majority back to really get answers from
this administration who's completely
ignoring republican calls for
information yeah i don't think the
american people signed up for a proxy
war with russia and as they're suffering
financially so many families this is
just absolutely outrageous it's it's a
slap in the face i'm going to move to
another topic which is the border
there's as you know
a lot of problems i mean and you're
pointed out rightly that there's not
enough funding for border patrol and so
much of it is going to places we don't
know
last week a good samaritan discovered 70
pounds of cocaine that was washed up
along the coastline in the florida keys
the border patrol agents
with support from the monroe county
sheriff's office recovered the drugs
which have an estimated street value of
over a million dollars as you know we
have a massive fentanyl problem um what
what's your reaction to this discovery
and all the problems we're having with
drugs as a result of the open border
yeah we we have had enough fentanyl come
into the united states to kill six times
the population of the united states all
under joe biden the drugs that are
coming across the border is absolutely
astronomical because we have an open
border over 3.1 million
illegal crossings since joe biden has
been president there's only 2.1 million
people that live in miami-dade county
that's more than all of the population
of miami-dade county and another million
on top of that it's absolutely atrocious
we have an invasion at our southern
border yet we want to give this this
administration wants to give money to
ukraine for a proxy war when republicans
get back in control that's where the
power of the purse is going to come in
where we can use the appropriations
process to say you know what you can't
spend any money at the department of
homeland security to now allow a legal
immigrant to come into our country yeah
i sure hope our leadership in the
republican party does do that with the
war in ukraine there was a lot of
a lot of news and up and to the ramp-up
of this war and now we're hearing
nothing about the money and as you said
it could have gone to the into the hands
of some pretty corrupt oligarchs so
thank you so much for staying on this
the american people really do appreciate
it congressman thank you i'm steve ducey
i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainslie
earhart and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis